here on a Thursday morning this is Bike
To Work Week and the RTC has some free
activities to try and entice you to
ditch the four wheels and just stick
with two all month long you can gear up
for a little fun Candace Charles joining
us live from Pedego electric bikes in
Henderson with the benefits of all that
Pedal Power Candace good morning to you
hey good morning YouTube good morning
folks that's riding a bike to work
really is not only good for your own
health but for the community and I'm at
Pedego electric bikes right now which
really makes it easier for you to get
that going I have riding the pettico pup
with me right over there as well as
Jordan Clark the owner with me thank you
so much for joining us tell us a little
bit about how these electric bikes make
it easier to get that started that Bike
To Work Week started it's great we have
a lot of customers to ride their bikes
to work every every day it's cheaper
it's quicker it gets you out there and
active and it's also just a great way to
hang out with your friends too now I
know you have different levels on this
bike I tried out myself you guys it
definitely is quite easy to use explain
how well when you're uh this this bike
has pedal assist so it helps you pedal
but you choose how much help the bike
gets you so you can really get a great
workout on it but at the same time if
you need a little help getting up a hill
it's right there to help you out I love
that that's amazing Jordan thank you so
much the bikes range for about 2500 to
3500 and these are class two bikes right
so you can ride them out on the road
here's a few safety tips for you guys
always remember to wear your helmet
check your tires before getting on the
road ride in the flow of traffic not
against it you want to stay in the bike
lane if you can drivers make sure you're
taking a heat to those those Riders out
on the bike lane and don't drive in the
bike lane you guys we got you covered
with all these details as well on our
website innewsnow.com as I mentioned RTC
has a bunch of events for this month and
for Bike To Work Day this Friday they
have a huge event we got those details
on their website and newsnow.com
let's do it
yeah
oh that's fun yes it's just like the
Tour de France